では始まります なぜ忙しいということは
仏教の立場から 忙しいということをまず定義を覚えておいてください
この世間の時間と人の時間の組み合わせなんですね Why
are you so busy? How does Buddhism view this aspect? このbusyということは
仏教はどのように見ているのかということ
はい まあ大体読むだけで十分だと思います
忙しい まず仏教ではこの意味はもう大事なんですよ
言葉の ただ無批判で言葉を使わない
いつでも定義してみようとはするんです
それで仏教的な定義 一致しない2種類の時間の流れありますね
1番目は普遍的な外の世界の時間の流れ
これは普通のフロータイムと言うんですね
ただ 世間の流れがあります
2番目は個人 人間個人の時間の流れ
だから世間に時計がありまして
個人にも時計があるということなんです
外の流れは常に一定ですが
個人の時間感覚はまちまちです
決まって遅いです 個人の時計は
これが忙しいということです
だって世間に合わせなくちゃあかんでしょうに
だからのんびりできないんですよ
のんびりできないんだけど
足が遅いんです だから各人の時間は遅いんです
世間の時間は一定しているんです
これは定義のある第一歩で
それ全てじゃないんです
まだまだ結構ありますが
次に行きます 難しくないんですから
それで基本的な仏教教理学的なところから分析してみます
基本的には物質ルーパですね
の変化の流れは一定しています
物質っていうのは一定の速さで変化していく
物質の組み合わせで様々な現象ができた時
それぞれが自分の時間を持っている
これがたとえで言えばわかります
仏教で物質っていうのは地水火風ですね
科学的に言えば素粒子みたいなもんなんですね
素粒子は一定の速さで流れているんです
しかし 素粒子固まって豆腐出来上がったりすると
米が出来上がったりすると
ご飯が出来上がったりすると
米は違う ご飯 また違う時計を持っちゃう
豆腐は違う時計を持っちゃう
大豆は別な時計を持っちゃう
しかし 大豆が物質ってことじゃないんですよ
本当に素粒子が物質なんです
だから大豆もご飯も同じ素粒子できてますよ
素粒子といえば 8種類しかないんだから
科学の世界でも 8個しかないんです
その8個でできているんです
だからこの素粒子は一定の時間で変化していくんです
なのに素粒子が固まって大豆になったら別な時間になる
豆腐になったらまた別な時間
そのへんは大豆が腐れる時間であって
素粒子は腐れる時間ではありません
豆腐が腐れる時間であってということなんです
だから現象っていうのはもう大豆
豆腐のことで もうすべて現象ですよ
素粒子は存在しないんですね
素粒子はいつでも固まって
もう何か幻想か何かになっちゃうんです
人間も手を加えて現象を作ったり変えたりする
それで人間も世界を変えたりするでしょ
例えば 2日で腐るはずの豆腐を
1ヶ月とか経っても腐らないようにするというのは人間の手なんですね
現象を変える能力は心の能力な力なのです
なんで我々に世界をね
もう変えることできるのか
例えば大豆だったら まあ 1年 2
年ぐらいは持ちますよ
人間手を加えて豆腐にする
豆腐にしたらせいぜい 2日ですね
そういう風になっちゃうんですよ
なんでそんな大胆なことできるんですかね
人間には これ 人間の腕の力じゃないんです
人間の心の力なんです
だから心はすごいもんですよ
2日でなくなるはずの豆腐を 1ヶ月間持つようにすることもできるし
1年も 2年も持てる大豆を 2日でダメになるように豆腐にすることもできるし
そうやっていろいろ変化できますよ
これもまあ一応ダーウィンさんから考えたことです
はい 次に行きます それから時間の流れ
世間編 現象を変える心
心がものを変えたり 新しいものを作ったりしたくなる
心にそういう気持ちがあるんです
変えやと これでは嫌やと
肉は生で食えんと やっぱり焼き肉にしようかと
というふうに心が思うんですよ
変えたいものを瞬時に変えたいが
そうそうはいかないんでしょ
もう生の生肉がある 生では食べたくない
で 焼き肉にしたいと言ったら
瞬時に焼き肉にしたいんですよ
人間は 生肉はたちまち焼き肉になったらすごくありがたいんです
しかし そうはいかないでしょうに
なんとか焼き肉 何で作るんですかね
あれ なんとか鉄板とかね
何か持ってきて また火をつけて
いろいろつけるものやら
もう大変な準備がかかるんですよ
たちまちはできません
だから いくら心で物事を変えようと思っても
因果法則に従わなくてはならないんです
わがまま言うんじゃないんです
たちまちもう生の肉はもう焼き肉になりましたと
それはありえないんです
充電が完了しました で
因果法則に従わなくちゃいけない
それを無視する人は焦ったり
混乱したり 怒ったり 妄想したり
夢ばかり見たり またいろいろな現実離れの物語を作ったりする
だからみんなそうでしょう
この因果法則を無視する
ものを変えたい 変えたいんだけど
なかなかそううまくいかない
気持ち通りには だって因果法則がありますからね
ご飯食べたいんだけど
あるのは米です 米はご飯にしたいが
40分 45 分かかりますよ
たちまちにご飯にしたいでしょ
瞬時に みんなそういうまるっきり因果法則を無視する思考を持ってますよ
だから世の中で神話 物語
アラディンの物語とか
いくらでもあります 魔法の物語
あのあれ マジックワンドなんて言いますか？魔法の杖
杖振ったらもう全部変わったとか
シンデレラ物語とかいくらでもあります
現代映画って何ですかね
同じアラディンの物語でしょ
サイエンスフィクションやら色々言いたい
もう名前をつけたりして
ただの昔やっていたような感じで
インチキ物語を作るだけ
しかし アジアで作った物語はいつでも何か道徳ある
前言ったでしょ 鬼の話は
あれは役に立ちますよ
しかし アラディンのランプの物語で
どこでどう役に立つのかと
道徳ないんです ただ夢見て因果法則を知らないんだから
夢見ているだけ で 他人に当たったり文句を言ったりもする
これよくありますね 自分の期待通りに早く物事もうまくいかないと
あなたのせいではないかとか
人に当たったりとかね
で 文句言ったりもする
やっぱり因果法則の中で生活しなくちゃいけないんですよ
わがままはできないんです
はい それはまあはい 同じ時間内で複数のことを変えようとする
また 愚かな人間が同じ時間内で複数のことを変えようとするんですよ
この今 私は変えるという言葉を使ってますよ
側変では仕事という言葉を使っていたんです
その区別を覚えておいてください
仏教になってくる仕事という言葉じゃない
ただ物は変わる それだけ
そこで人は変わるものは変えようとする
それもあり得る 米は炊かなくてもやがて腐っていきますからね
だからその場合は米は変わる
でも洗って炊飯器に入れる場合は
米を変えるなんです だから変わる変えるの差は別にどうったことない
それも物事は変わるという一定した法則の上で成り立っているんです
そこで我々は複数のことをやろうとする
例えば 料理をしながら仕事もする
同時に子供の相手もする
これが忙しいということなんです
料理も作りながら内職もして
同じ時間でまた子供の相手もしてあげると
同じ時間で仕事を 3つしようとしているんです
要するに合理性が薄く
無知と欲 無知と欲か怒りが目立つ
そうすると人間どうなるかというと
合理性がなくなっちゃうんです
欲と怒りが結構目立つんですよ
無知 無知だから全部やろうとするんですよ
例えば 赤ちゃんの面倒を見ながら内職できるかと
どちらかって抜くんですよ
料理もしている場合は
料理をしている途中で赤ちゃんが泣いちゃうと
そちらに行かなくちゃいけないです
料理は失敗する だから同時にいろんなことをやろうとすると失敗するでしょ
あー忙しい 忙しい なんて忙しいのかと
子供は誰かないんでしょうかね
子供のちょっと相手してくれる人が
そんなことを言うんでしょう
これ 合理性がなくなったっていうことなんです
それから 無知と欲と欲か怒りがありすぎたんですね
変えたいものには法則
時間というものがあるんです
それぞれの現象が自分の時間を持っている
時間とは現象が変わるスピードのこと
明確に私は書いています
だから大豆は自分の時間を持っているということは
大豆は腐れてしまう時間です
豆腐は豆腐の時間を持っている
これさえ理解していただければ
忙しもなくなるはずです
仏教的にはこれぐらいのことを理解しておけばね
忙しいってことは消えますよ
ありえないんだ 忙しいっていうことは
ただ失敗しているだけ
赤ちゃんを面倒見ながら料理する場合は失敗しますよ
だから じゃあまず赤ちゃんが泣いてるんだったら慰めてあげて
おっぱいあげて で 寝かせておく
寝ている間で料理をするっていうことでしょうに
そうすると忙しいとは言えないんです
そんなもんです はい 次に行きます
えーと 心は物質よりはるかに速いんです
心は速いんです 理性 論理より感情というのは欲
怒り 高慢などですね 支配されている
心の問題は理性に支配されてないんですよ
論理に支配されてないんですよ
感情に支配されています
感情といえば 欲 怒り 高慢
落ち込み 嫉妬 舞い上がり
憎しみ 悲しみ もういっぱいあります
私は頭で考えて行動するんじゃなくて
欲か怒りか憎しみか嫉妬か
それがそれが入ってくると
何か必ず動いちゃう で
次は え これ漢字が 違うでしょうね
変わりたく  変わりたく
あるいは変えたくなった時でも構いませんね
じゃあ変えたくなったと書きましょうか
うん 変えたくなった瞬間で結果を期待する
元の例を考えてください
生の肉があってお腹も空いていて
やっぱり焼肉食べたいと思っちゃうと
その瞬時に焼肉を食べたくなるんですよ
本当は その時は誰もそう思わないですよ
一応なぜか外ちゃんと理性働いてますよ
焼肉だったら鉄板を持ってきて
これこれであって まあこれぐらいめたくなったら
これぐらい時間を焼かなくちゃいけないと
論理が働くんだから 別に忙しいとは思わないでしょ
もし理性がない子供がいたら
焼肉食べたい 早くくれと言うでしょうに
まだ肉は生のまんまなのに
お母ちゃん早くくれと
その時は理性がないでしょう
だから大人もだいたいそういうことはもう結構あります
焼肉の場合はその問題はないんだけど
例えばご飯を食べたいと思う空腹感に気づいている
今食べたいがあるのは米と材料だけです
料理をする時間で 苛立ちも忙しさも感じるんですよ
例えば ものすごい空腹感の時
まあこれは今もうコンビニあるんだから
なかなかそれは皆様に経験ないでしょうし
だから本当に空腹感があって
田舎にいると思ってください
もう何もない 米はあるんだけど
野菜もある その用意しなくちゃいけないでしょ
その時すごく苛立ち感じるんですよ
忙しいと感じるんですよ
別に忙しいわけじゃないんだけど
早く食べたいという気持ちですよ
理性がないんですよ 感情だけ
お腹が空いた もう我慢できない
早く食べたいと だからその気持ちが入ると
忙しい 忙しいだけではなくて
苛立ちも出てくる はい
次に行きます 時間の流れのこと
したがって 忙しいとは人の非論理性を表すんです
仏教から見れば 忙しいと言った途端
あなたは論理的な人間じゃありませんよという意味なんです
ちょっとおかしいと 病気じゃないのかと
原因法則を無視することです
因果法則 原因法則 これをきれいさっぱり無視しているんです
それ無視して生きるわけないでしょうに
ありえないものを期待する結果です
なんで忙しいかというのかというと
ありえないものを期待する
だから忙しさ感じるんです
物事の因果法則を知る人にのみ忙しいは存在しないのです
それで因果法則を知っているんだったら
忙しいって感じないんです
存在もしない 忙しいっていうことは精神的な苛立ちですからね
いいことじゃないんですよ
因果法則を知っているとそれがないんです
例えば リンゴの種を蒔いたら
もう２ ３年かかると知ってるでしょうに
ちゃんと知ってる場合は何のことなくちゃんと増すでしょ
芽が出ているのかどうかね
殺草があるのかどうか
肥料はどうしようかとか
もう何年も面倒見るんですよ
それで３年経ったところへ
やっとリンゴを食べられますけど
その法則をわかっている場合は
全然苛立ちは何もないんです
人間はリンゴの種を蒔いて
明日リンゴあるのかと探す人一人見ないでしょうに
だから因果法則を知っていると
そういうのも落ち着いていられます
それで我々は何で忙しいか
感じているのかというと
その時点で因果法則も知っているんです
リンゴの場合も 米の場合も
生肉の場合も大丈夫ですけど
いろんなところで 肉瞬時に焼き肉になってホシッといるくつに戻るんです
それで忙しいと思っちゃう
まあそんなもんで次にいきます
もう簡単でしょ じゃあ
これからこの今説明したのは仏教的に世間の流れ
世間は因果法則だから
もうそれ変えられますよ
世界は変えられますが
因果法則の中で頑張ってくださいと
それはもうどうしようもないと
ここで個人の時間について仏教の立場
目まぐるしく変化していくこの世界についていけないと人が文句を言う
弱音を吐く 個人は大体そんなことを言うんですよ
世界はあまり早すぎてついていけないと
感情に支配されている心は
自己回転妄想で時間を浪費して世界の流れに遅れる
ただそれだけ 我々は感情に支配されているでしょう
だから心が自己回転するんです
妄想するんですよ 妄想するんだから
時間がなくなっちゃうんですよ
妄想して世界を見ると
もうとっくに変わっているんです
だからついていけないと言うんですよ
自分が妄想している間
世界は止まってくれないんですよ
時々お母さんたち言うでしょ
なんで子供はもう突然悪くなったんでしょうかと
言うことを聞かなくなったんでしょうかと
それも同じ結果なんです
うちの子はいい子だ いい子だよとかね
頭の中で妄想ばっかり何年もするんですよ
7  8年  10年も 可愛い子です
言うことよく聞いてくれる子やと
しかし 外の世界でしょ
子供は一瞬たりとも止まることなく
その子は変化しているんですよ
見てないんで それで10年経ってから見ると
あれ？ついていけないと
なんでこうなったのかと
毎日変化してそうなったんですけど
それですごい問題を起こしちゃうんですね
どうしようか どうしようかと
大体いつでもあることで
我々は妄想する 妄想している間は
世界は変わっている それで目が覚めて世界を見るとなんかついていけないと言い張っちゃうんです
光よりも早く変わる心は
この世の中の 嫌になるほど遅い変化の流れについていけないということなんですよ
これ 本当はありえないんですよ
心っていうのは光よりも早く変わるんですよ
光よりも心が早いんだったら
世の中の変化っていうのも遅くて遅くて嫌になるんですよ
本当の状態では じゃあ
素粒子レベルで皆さんアビダルマの達人たちだから知っていると思いますけど
素粒子のレベルで考えちゃうと
素粒子 1個が変化する間で心が 17回変化しているんですよ
だから心は 17倍速いんです
それが物質 どちらにしてもスピードは同じなんですよ
心が速いんですよ だってなんで新幹線は光のから次に開発した電車がのぞみになったんでしょうかね
光より速いんだからでしょ
当たり前の名前ですよ
あれは 光よりは心が速いんです
だからのぞみにしたんです
立派ですよ 名前は まあ子供はなすなそれにすぐ使ってますけどね
光より速いのは何？とかね
だから面白いです 光よりも速い心を持っていって
世間の流れにはついていけないということはね
それは妄想の結果です
どれほど妄想に時間とエネルギーを浪費しているのかと
わかるでしょうに これこれに
子供の変化にもついていけないと言っちゃうと
もう信じられないほど妄想してるんですよ
すっごいエネルギー すごい時間
はい 次に行きます えーと
ウサギがいや カメがウサギに勝るのは当然ということで
物質の変化についていけないのはありえないんです
妄想にふけっている心が目を覚まして外を見ると
わからないほど変わっている
だから妄想しているということは
まあ寝ていることに入れ替えてください
ウサギとカメがもう競争に出たところで
ウサギは寝ちゃったでしょうに
途中でグーグーと そこで我々も妄想ということで寝ているんですよ
たまに目が覚めてみると
あれ 世界がわからなくなってるんだということになるんです
妄想という快楽に依存しながら
世界の流れに遅れないようにするから
忙しいという感覚が現れる
これで忙しいの現れなんです
妄想という快楽で寝ているんですよ
しかし 世間の流れにもついていきたいんです
ありえないんです 妄想しているんだったら遅れてくださいと
しかないんです 何もできんと
そこで妄想もしながら世間と一緒に生きていきたいんでしょ
そうすると忙しいと感じちゃうんですよ
もうやりきれないんだと
やることいっぱいあるんだと思っちゃうんです
しかし 時間とエネルギーを浪費している人間に遅れないことは無理な話
無理な期待 だから忙しいと感じない人間はいないんです
だってみんな妄想してエネルギーを浪費してるでしょ？時間も浪費してるでしょうに
だからみんな自慢げに忙しいと言うんです
あんなの恥ずかしげで言うものじゃないんですよ
本当は 仏教から言えば
忙しいと言ったらもう結構病気になるほど忙しい
妄想しているということなんです
はい 次 心の内は忙しいということで
で あの これに行く前に
前のちょっとなぜウサギとカメが作ったですけど
カメは止まらないでしょ
カメっていうのは外の世界なんですよ
外の世界はゆっくりのんびり同じスピードで変わっていくんですよ
しかし ウサギが負けちゃったんですよ
あいつは寝ちゃったんだから
それで我々人間はいつでも忙しいと言ってるんですよ
我々ウサギなんですよ
世界はのんびり回ってるんだから
もう結構気楽にカメと一緒に行けますよ
カメと一緒に行くか 先に行ってゴールに行くか
何でもできますよ なのにカメが勝っちゃう
だから我々はどんな人間でも忙しい忙しいと文句言いながら負けて
みんな死ぬんですよ 負けとして
敗者として 誰も勝てない人生には
だからそれは妄想ということです
妄想してものすごい時間とエネルギーを失くなる
はい 次のスライドに行きます
したがって 落ち着いていない
理性に基づかない 因縁法則を無視する
感情に支配されている心は忙しいという幻想を湧かすんです
忙しいということは幻想なのです
化け物です ありえないんです
まるっきりありえないんです
これがこの落ち着いてないから
理性がないから 因果法則も無視しているから
感情に支配されているから出てくる化け物です
幻想です はい 次 これは苛立ち
失敗 ストレス これまた文章を間違っていますね
まあなどですね などの以後で表わ...なんか表すんですよ
表しています まあとにかく
この我々 苛立ち 失敗 ストレスとかいろんな言葉がありますね
その言葉でこの同じ忙しいという言葉なんですよ
ストレス溜まっていると言ったっても同じです
忙しいという意味なんです
苛立ってるなと言えば
それまた忙しさ感じてるんです
以後がたくさんなります
自慢げに胸を張って言うものではないのです
忙しいと 言った時点ですごいおかしいということになっちゃうんです
ウサギだと 勝つのはもうカメだからね
はい それから別な これで仏教的な説明は一部終わりました